this actually i think is one of the most
important things that people should
understand because so much of how people
often revise is passive it's where
you're looking at information and it
makes you feel intelligent because of
course everything you're looking at is
right you know you're looking at a
diagram with everything already labeled
for you and you're nodding away feeling
like you're putting it in your brain
you're flicking through that textbook
you're re rereading your notes you're
spending hours rereading it just feels
like you are full of information but in
reality none of that is going in
hi jade welcome to the show
hello chris it is an honor to be here
tell me
about your university you're doing this
multi city
yes so i go to a relatively new
university it's called minerva it's
based in san francisco and it's like a
super international cohort of people but
every semester we move
so me and all my friends we moved to
different cities that have been
predefined by the university and so it's
kind of a study abroad but built into
the fabric of how the degree works so my
first year i spent in san francisco and
then last year i lived in seoul in south
korea this time i'll be studying in
berlin in germany so it is this crazy
whirlwind of a degree for sure
are you becoming one of those russian
secret agent things because this sounds
like
this sounds like one of those presents
i mean that's also what a russian secret
agent that's exactly what they would say
to try and cover their tracks
that is true i'm just packaged in a
innocent looking girl
yeah perhaps so what are you studying do
you still choose courses in the same way
yes so because it's the us system um you
can do a major and a minor and i've
chosen to do a double major in cognitive
neuroscience and business brand
management so very different things
which i think gets across how indecisive
i am but i really love learning so
yeah kind of got the science in there
but also more practical business stuff i
like it yeah so given that you've made a
youtube channel and released a book
specializing in study tips why do you
think it is that no one ever actually
teaches us how to study
in school because there's obviously a
demand for this
for sure this is a question i ask myself
a lot because i think a lot in the
school system will be solved if only
there were dedicated classes teaching
you about the science of learning about
you know how humans learn and i think
they try sometimes there's things like
oh are you a visual learner or an
auditory learner which often misses the
point because you're asking
you know students to work out themselves
as opposed to
looking back at real research about how
all humans learn and then using that as
a base for you to then go away and
practice your own revision techniques
which work for you
um honestly i think a lot of the school
system is outdated so it's probably just
something that hasn't been caught up
with yet
yeah i don't know it's
part of me thinks that
it would make the teachers lives a lot
easier
if what you're fighting with for the
most part is just combating the fact
that the students don't understand how
retention works i don't understand how
to link different concepts together
so
if i was a teacher
no matter what subject it is why not
just spend the first couple of
days of whatever course it is or even at
university if you talk yeah if you took
the first hour of the first lecture it's
just about look this is what
how learning works
yeah there you go it would just make the
rest of the life of your life so much
easier
for sure and especially because so much
emphasis is put on your exam grades like
effectively you know your whole school
life is thinking about how can i
condense this textbook into my mind and
then put that onto a piece of paper to
get a grade which is going to determine
the university that i go to potentially
the job i get where i live like the
whole rest of my life and that crucial
step between you know first learning it
in the classroom and then getting those
exam results is missing from the
education system that middle part of how
to revise is up to students
how would you characterize the sort of
student that you were and uh
oh i love learning so i'm um i was kind
of that nerdy student in the back
who would sort of keep my head down and
just get on with my work and i really
liked what i was doing
i went to a very average state school so
i often felt quite alienated for loving
learning as much as i did and um yeah i
was just kind of
thought of myself as very uncool and
there were times where i
um
i you know tried to dull the fact that i
like learning and
to you know to fit in or to pretend to
be cool or more popular um but
i don't know now i think i've really
embraced it and that's part of why my
youtube channel where i i pioneered a
space called studytube which is all
about learning and other students who
want to get better at learning or enjoy
it
it's a really big thing for me because
it sort of validated this this love of
school that's what the internet's done
right it's permitted people that were
niched down so hard that they couldn't
find someone to resonate with
in the real world
it's allowed them to find other people
that they can build a community around
for sure
yeah and i never expected to take off
can you imagine my surprise when i was
there making videos like study with me
for half an hour study with me for an
hour i would literally be
revising something for a test i had the
next day and would just record it on my
phone and videos like that would
sometimes get a million views
and think about how hard it is now to
get a million views look at all of the
work that you have to put into a video
going to places doing things yeah for
sure nightmare should have just put just
just put it on so we've just been
studying chris i know what the heck all
right so how do we learn what are the
basics
okay so something i talk about in my
book is an acronym i came up with which
is
sad so s double a d and the idea is like
revision can be very sad it can be kind
of a miserable experience so
rather than it being sad how can you
turn it sad
and each of these things stand for a
little hack based off the science of
learning um where i you know i've done
loads of research into different
academic papers and evidence-based
techniques sort of boiled it down to
four things that you can look at every
way that you're revising to question
yourself whether it's actually effective
or not
and uh i don't know if you want me to
run through what those are yes i guess
i've led a bit of mystery now yes so the
first one is s which is space repetition
so this is the idea of the forgetting
curve of human memory
so um
yeah how we learn is humans we often
like to sit there we like to cram think
we're studying by revising for 10 hour
blocks and then
going away and not reviewing this
information for a very long time but
that's not how human memory works we
start off a hundred percent of whatever
we've learned and then it exponentially
decreases human memory just absolutely
decays over time so you can imagine you
know you've had a class you've had a new
lesson on something in biology and then
two days later you can't even remember a
single thing you've just looked at
and then when you come to revise it
again in a month you're starting totally
from scratch because you don't even
remember what you first learnt
so the idea of space repetition is you
can hack human memory by reviewing this
information at regularly increasing
intervals so for example you have that
day in your classroom where you've
learned something new then the day after
you go back and you look at it then
three days after you go back and look at
it five days seven days and you slowly
increase that time and all of a sudden
it's being put into your long-term
memory so that is the first s is space
repetition
and you know that applies to any
technique you're going to use whether
that's flash cards or
even highlighting your notes if you are
going to be repeating it it's going to
go in more a lot a lot better than doing
it once in a blue moon do you know what
that applies to physical skills as well
i wouldn't be surprised if it does but i
don't have a lot of um a lot of
expertise on like muscle memory and that
kind of thing
yeah but i wouldn't be surprised because
i guess it's still a facet of human
learning
interesting all right what's the a
okay so we've got two a's in here we've
got active recall
so this is this actually i think is one
of the most important things that people
should understand
because
so much of how people often revise is
passive it's where you're looking at
information and it makes you feel
intelligent because of course everything
you're looking at is right you know
you're looking at a diagram with
everything already labeled for you and
you're nodding away feeling like you're
putting it in your brain you're flicking
through that textbook you're re
rereading your notes you're spending
hours rereading it just feels like you
are full of information
but in reality none of that is going in
and it's actually really
counter-intuitive how learning works
it's less about what you're putting in
and breathing into your brain it's more
about what you're testing yourself on
and what you're dragging out and that is
what active recall is
it's sitting down
asking yourself tough questions about
the topic that you're trying to learn
and
trying to find the answers yourself and
if you can't find them you you can then
look at them and then the next day
you're going to ask yourself the
questions again so it's it's finding
revision techniques which are yeah
requiring that more active element
so that's something like active recall
is something that i never knew was a
thing
when i was at when i was at uni
bonkers
it is bonkers and it's crazy because
you know even the aesthetic of studying
i feel is highlighting you know you have
pastel highlighters and you feel really
good about it
and jade that's just oh maybe that's
just me in the aesthetic like study
tumblr world but
yeah there's something about
highlighting information which makes you
feel like you're doing something
valuable but when you look into the
science of it it doesn't actually
do that much for you yeah it has to be
repeated recall not repeated exposure
like that's the difference between the
two and you're totally correct
as you
look at something
over and over again you become more
familiar with it but familiarity and
recall ability are not the same thing
but they cannot they can kind of like
seem
like they're the same thing as you read
a page oh yeah yeah that bit the
paragraph about about
the berlin wall or whatever it is that
you're learning about
you know what's coming up but you don't
know it enough to be able to close the
textbook and do it so what's a
what's a good way for someone to do
active recall just look at it
look at a question close it try and
answer it
so one of my favorite techniques which i
talk about in a different chapter of how
to apply these methods is called
blurting
and the idea is
it's a horrible name isn't it but
it's memorable
i was going to say i've talked about
this on my youtube channel before and i
think it's the most popular eurovision
method that's been discussed i have
people even to this day like messaging
me being like jade blarting has changed
my life
all right well that's all done let's
hold on to that let's finish off sad and
then we'll get into
that that word that i really don't want
to
say um
so yeah the other a is associations
which is the idea that whenever you're
learning something new if you can
associate it to something you already
know
the likelihood that you're going to
remember it and that you're gonna you're
gonna make sense of it is exponentially
higher so i use a non-study example um
just to explain this to people is how i
i'm off able to remember people's names
quite well if you think you know you're
at a party you're going round you're
meeting so many new people and when you
hear someone's name the odds are you've
forgotten about it before they've even
finished saying it
and the way that you can remember names
more easily is if when the second you
hear their name trying to associate it
to something else that you know about
either that name or
the way that person looks or something
about that word and an example i give is
you know say someone is called charlotte
that's a that's a standard name very
easy to forget but if in that one or two
seconds you can think about a charlotte
that you know maybe your neighbor's
called charlotte and you're you're
taking one second just to think oh this
person doesn't really look like my
neighbor charlotte or oh i don't know
like just some something some element of
the name that brings up an association
or memory um just means that the next
time you see that person you're bringing
to mind this association that you've
created for yourself and you're more
likely to bring that word that name back
and the way that you can apply this to
studying is say you're learning
something new in a classroom
um when you're learning something if you
can instantly think okay how does this
link to the last class i took how does
this link to a different topic or even a
different subject how does this work for
a test question i've seen and even just
scribbling notes on the side like oh
i've seen something like this before
is really increasing the associations
and the the rate of retention that
you'll have because you're building on
foundations of your
existing knowledge all right d
d desirable difficulty
so this is the idea that we don't really
like to challenge ourselves naturally
you're always going to reach for what
feels easy
and so that means if a subject you're
really good at it you're more likely to
go back and study it than that subject
that you really hate so it's constantly
questioning does this feel really easy
for me right now and if it does how can
i make it harder
so maybe you're looking at a flash card
set and it's just got quite easy for you
then it's time to move on to test
questions or practice papers or
something that while you're doing it
feels like a challenge and that's how
you know you're you're spending your
time well
i like it okay so that's the four
fundamental pillars
of how we study and how we learn
what are the most effective study
methods
okay so
um i list ten in my book uh one of which
is i know you don't like the word it's
awful
it is awful but you know what you're
going to blurt out your knowledge so it
is memorable
[Music]
that knowledge chris
all right so let's learn let's learn
that one first
yes
okay so the idea is you take something
that you're trying to learn trying to
remember
maybe it's um a process in science
that's just you know not sticking with
you and you're like cool i'm gonna
revise this what you do is you write
yourself a few prompt words about the
process
or about the chapter and then you
effectively write down you blurt down
everything you can remember
from your brain like everything based
off these prompt words so you're listing
out the process you're listing out
keywords you draw diagrams uh whatever
you can remember if it's english
literature and you've you're you're um
you're trying to blur a theme or about
character you're just writing down
whatever you can remember
and then you're going back and you're
comparing what you've written down to
your notes or to a textbook and straight
away you can see how much you do and
don't know
like there's no line to yourself anymore
there's no reading the textbook
is the aim to try and replicate the
textbook as closely as possible is it
just sort of rote memorization here what
we actually aiming for
yes it depends on the subject so
unfortunately the way that our academic
system often works is a lot of
memorization is necessary so especially
science topics you have to get things
almost word for word as the mark scheme
wants it in order to get a grade and so
these are the moments where you do want
to be able to produce that from your
head you don't want to just understand
it you want to be able to um yeah recall
it
so blurting is where you can write that
down and then compare it to your notes
and straight away see what you're not
strong in but i think it's also a good
way to test your understanding
because it's one thing to say that you
understand how a historical event
happened and understand the causes but
when it comes to writing it down or
explaining it to a friend teaching
someone else you instantly see these
gaps in your knowledge and then writing
it down it's just a more formal way of
testing yourself and then looking back
and be able to fill in those gaps all
right what's another one
uh flash cards
simple easy i'm sure you're familiar
with flash cards right
are we talking anki or are we talking
highlighters on the top of a piece of
paper
yes so you can do both but the beauty of
anki i don't know if all the listeners
are familiar with it
it's a flashcard software that already
has the idea of space repetition built
into it so you've made your flash card
and they will go back and test you on
things that you get wrong they're going
to test your regular intervals so it
supports the science of learning within
the app but you can also do this with
you know with your your classic pen your
paper
um and
the beauty of flashcards is you can put
test questions on it you're writing
something on one side and then it
invites that active recall from yourself
because you're not seeing the answer
straight away you have to turn over the
flash card to get the answer out of
yourself so that's a really good
technique all right give us one more
uh
um
maybe like quite a niche one
just because that's fun
um i don't know if you've heard of
sherlock's mind palace
i have heard of sherlock you have yes
um so the idea is it's like object
association so what sherlock did in
order to remember a lot of facts is he
would create rich retrieval cues and
those retrieval cues can be objects so
thinking about in your house
imagine yourself walking into your
living room can be a prompt for you
remembering a fact or a piece of
knowledge so if you think every single
time that you're going to look in your
mirror you're going to repeat a certain
fact to yourself in your head then when
you're trying to recall that fact you
can just think back to a certain
location and it will just be a prompt
for you to remember that
how similar is that to the associations
thing that you brought up earlier on
that just sounds like a direct
sort of a direct correlation
oh you mean the the concept of
association yeah yeah yeah that's like
the most direct way to do it really
exactly yes which is why
it's kind of supported by evidence and
science of learning that it works so if
you were to go through that sad
framework on each of the techniques i
just mentioned it sort of ticks all the
boxes as being something that is
actually effective
it's interesting i did a talk earlier
this year and i searched the internet to
find out what's the best way to remember
an 18-minute talk and tons and tons of
people suggested to do some sort of a
mind palace but just through your house
so you're walking into your house and
the first sentence is there at the front
door and then you turn into the living
room
for me personally that felt like
it was almost as much work to create the
house as it was to remember it and i
just ended up going to sort of brute
force memorization through a bit of
space repetition and active recall and
that was that was perfectly fine so i'm
going to guess that there must be times
where people can over complicate the
learning process by trying to use too
many tools or by trying to use
inappropriate tools
yes
i find techniques like this should be
used really sparingly it's if there's
something that just for whatever reason
isn't going into your head like i think
there was one
process or something that i just
couldn't get my head around like you
know ask friends and it just wasn't
going in and then turning to techniques
like this which are a little bit
different almost to make it fun too
because it's not fun to go over and keep
learning something that you don't
understand or you don't like
yeah so you shouldn't use this for
everything but is proven to be a good
technique when used effectively cool how
should people schedule their study
timetable
okay so um this again is is personal
preference some people like to schedule
minute to minute but something i discuss
in my book is sort of your do's and
don'ts for timetabling based off of
other people's experiences and research
yeah so
what you've got to do to create a good
timetable is
practice like you need to get good at
estimating how long things take you to
do when you've got 24 subjects 24 exams
sorry at gcse some people you know take
12 or 13 subjects you've got a lot of
things to juggle and the beauty of a
timetable is you're using you're
optimizing your time before that exam to
make sure that you're going over
everything most effectively
but in order to plan stuff you need to
know how long it's going to take you to
go over flash cards or
how long is actually realistic going to
take you to
do some blurting for that thing that you
don't remember
um so yeah so i really recommend just
even for
to for today or for tomorrow look at
your afternoon um and
just just try like go on google calendar
schedule like five to ten minutes for
whatever you're trying to learn and
instantly you'll probably see your um uh
you're underestimating how long it takes
you to do stuff so then you can go back
you can
improve upon your methods of how how
your estimation works
um
i'd say always be super generous with
yourself as well when you're planning
things uh like leave an extra 10 minutes
something which i see people not doing a
lot is leaving shuffle time
like plan shuffle time in between
activities
shuffle time is
you putting away your folders you
getting out your textbooks you opening
up anki so when you're going from one
activity to another
people will often on their timetable
just sort of put it at the same time so
like when i get to 6 pm i'm going to
stop writing flash cards and i'm going
to start
i don't know blurting
but then they don't leave this five to
ten minutes and then all of a sudden
you're you're running to catch up with
your timetable because you're a few
minutes behind so leaving like 10
minutes in between is just a really good
way to
be generous with yourself to leave time
to
um i don't know go get a drink of water
yeah how can people how should people
break this up should they break it up by
topic should they break it up by
learning style is it best to spend an
entire day on let's say that it is gcses
or it's university or whatever is it
best to stick to one module for an
entire day or
are you supposed to interleave her talk
to me about that
yes um it's cool you bring up
interleaving actually so there is
science which suggests that if you go
between topics you're more likely to
recall them than just being deep in one
for too long so i think the best way to
do it is firstly write down all the
topics that you've got to learn like
every every chapter every module um and
sort of plan how you're going to do your
timetable by looking at how difficult
your findings how much attention they
need
and the urgency so this is a process i
go through in my book of ranking your
subjects and where you're at with them
um so if you know that one thing is
gonna is a lot harder you can rank it as
a red or an amber or a green and based
off of that funnel it into your
timetable
based on how long it needs and then when
you're looking at individual days of
planning it i think it's also worth
thinking about when you work best so
some people that's early morning some
people
you know do work better late at night
and thinking about tackling the hardest
subjects at the time that you're
naturally the best and most on it so for
me that tended to be the morning
um so you could put those tasks in the
morning especially the ones that you're
not looking forward to like writing
practice essays or lengthy ones
and then interleaving it in between with
subjects that just have a lower
cognitive load for you based off of how
naturally you find it what about taking
breaks or moving in between
stuff like that because getting out of
flow and getting back into flow can be
difficult and sometimes taking a break
can be more detrimental but then yeah
after a while you get diminishing
returns have you got any
advice on how long people should try and
block for for sure so this actually runs
into the next chapter which is the
pomodoro technique i'm sure you're
familiar with it it's an amazing
productivity hack but also a great way
to plan your timetables and the idea is
that you set a timer for 25 minutes
which is one pomodoro and you choose
just one task to focus on for the full
25 minutes and if you get distracted you
start the timer again and it really
encourages you to not be half revising
where you're half on your phone and half
doing one thing or
jumping around between topics so you
spend the 25 minutes doing that one one
one thing and then you reward yourself
with a five minute break and i find five
minutes is a really good amount of time
to
actually relax but not get distracted
so you know you're being intentional
you're going to the toilet you're
getting a drink you're doing whatever um
but because you've set the timer up
you're not going to get distracted like
you're not going to overly scroll or get
too lost in messaging someone or
facetiming a friend because you know
that you've got your next pomodoro
already ready to go and it's only one
one task that you're gonna be focusing
on again
what are some of the biggest mistakes
that you think people make with regards
to productivity
oof um so many
um i think one of the biggest mistakes
in productivity is thinking that you
have to be on all the time and almost
the definition of what productivity is
to me productivity is spending time well
that's the definition
and
when we're thinking about the grind or
the hustle in exam season that can often
be equated to just sitting there and
doing work of some kind you know that's
like studying smarter or studying harder
i think productivity is often equated to
this study harder you know revive like
flick the textbook more keep inhaling
more information just do do do
and not stopping to question what the
productivity what the productive
activity actually is and what the output
out of it should be
um and i go through an equation in my
book of how i define productivity and
what makes up successful productivity
um i can go through that if that's
helpful yeah absolutely i mean just to
just to kind of book end that i think
you are correct that
the hustle
side of productivity suggests that
you should have your nose on the
grindstone
but the number of times that i was in
uni and i'd look across and people would
be in the library for the entire day
just to be able to say that they'd been
in the library for the entire day but
they hadn't spent more than an hour or a
couple of hours
doing their revisions so you've had a
miserable day in a place that you don't
want to be surrounded by crap food where
you haven't actually achieved anything
and then you get home and you're
completely ashamed of yourself and super
guilty you've had a rubbish day but you
haven't even been able to benefit from
the fact that you didn't do revision
which is actually what you did you
didn't you didn't get much revision done
yeah and you just decided to kind of
i don't know
tether yourself to the library in the
desperate attempt to make some revision
happen
for sure
yeah and i think what's truly productive
is
getting the meaningful output getting
that deep work but also scheduling like
fun stuff you know like getting it off
of the desk and relaxing or doing
mindfulness watching your favorite tv
show spending time with friends all
these
equally productive activities because
they mean you're also spending your time
well and that you're going to be
refreshed when you do go back to sit
down at that desk what's an over-hyped
productivity tool or strategy
oh
um
[Music]
i think
screen time blocks on social media are a
bit over hyped
you know where people will set a limit
of like 30 minutes a day for instagram
or tick tock because
i think people are almost setting a
challenge up for themselves to like use
that up and then like i encourage you
you're like oh you know i've got that
amount allowed today so you you sit
there and you go on it and then when
eventually the little thing pops up to
tell you've reached your limit you can
just click it away and just continue
scrolling and it's it's really easy
so i think thinking more about
systems of how you're learning and
systems for going on social media as
opposed to
like short-term hacks and short-term
limits
what's your system for controlling
social media use
yeah um so it comes back to timetabling
for me just thinking about my priorities
so if i know i've got an exam in a few
days
the priority should be doing effective
revision it doesn't need to take up the
whole day but if i can put that into my
into my timetable first you just feel
great when you've got like the most
important things done and then social
media is great too like it isn't just
procrastination like it's also super
enjoyable and you should be able to like
go and go on a mindless scroll um so i
think it's it's setting up the other
stuff first and planning that in advance
so you don't feel guilty when you are
doing so-called mindless activities all
right so what about productivity hacks
for studying what are your best ones
yeah so the pomodoro technique is
definitely one of the best um but i also
love the idea of sanctity of space
i don't know if you've heard of this
before
it's the idea that you have only one
location for a certain thing
so if you think about the way you're
setting up your brain when you go to the
kitchen you're thinking oh i'm going to
eat or i'm going to make food
generally when you lie down in bed
you're thinking oh i'm going to relax or
i'm going to go to sleep
so it's thinking about when you are at
your desk
what do you want to be doing
what is your brain coming to associate
your desk with is it
like scrolling on your phone is it also
calling your friends and studying
like when you go to the library are you
thinking oh cool i can go meet my mates
and we can go chat there and sit there
and just chill
so if you can develop one space which is
where you go to do your deep work
then that is
that is one of the best techniques
because you're creating a sanctity or
discipline around doing a certain
activity there and it means you're less
likely to overstay you're more likely to
be productive and do the work when you
need to
um yeah so i highly recommend that even
if it is
like staying behind at school or a
library like if home isn't the best
place to create that space but think
about the environmental triggers that
you have when you go to the gym everyone
during covid no one has ever worked out
as hard in the house as they have when
they actually go to the gym and it's
because of the ritual you pack your bag
and you get in the car and you put
spotify on and you listen to the thing
and you say hello to the receptionist
and you put your bag in the locker and
it's all part of the priming those
environmental triggers prime you it's
interesting there's an equivalent in
power
one of my buddies is
a really high level powerlifting
competitor
and he has a playlist of about four or
five songs that he only listens to when
he's going for a pr or when he's
competing so these songs if he hears
them come on in a a supermarket he'll
just sprint out of the supermarket or
he'll turn the radio off because he only
wants to hear that when it's time to be
100 switched on
yeah
and as you say it's a ritual right so
like for some people they'll have a
certain playlist like a study playlist
or a certain jumper that you're going to
put on like an outfit have you got a
revision outfit
um i i don't but revision sucks
just like you know like a slumpy like
cute outfit where you're like yeah okay
cool like
especially when you have to wear school
uniform in the uk there's just something
so nice about coming home and like
ripping that off and putting something
comfy on to get their work done
okay what else productivity hacks for
studying pomodoro technique keeping your
space sacred
ah yes
um are you familiar with the 80 20 rule
yes but not in terms of how it relates
to studying
yes um so this is kind of the whole
concept of work smarter not harder i
don't know so for everyone listening
who's not familiar with the 80 20
principle pareto principle the idea is
that 80
of the outcome or the grade that you're
going to get generally comes from 20 of
the input so if you think about all your
total time spent learning something in a
classroom or preparing revision
resources or going over those resources
doing practice papers like not all of
that is going to directly contribute to
you getting a mark in an exam or not and
so it's kind of working out what the 20
of your entire revision process is and
optimizing that
so that comes back to
using these techniques which are
guaranteed to work setting up your space
to allow yourself to get into that deep
work
um
yeah and then finding ways to optimo
optimize that 20 to get the most uh in
terms of grades and translating it to
the exams how do you identify that 20
yeah um so i think it it's going back to
like firstly the framework asking
yourself the questions of the the sad
technique so does it fit into
one of those four pillars
exactly is what i'm doing fitting into
those those four pillars then it's
likely fitting into this 20 of good
revision what would be an example of
something that
that people might do
that doesn't fit in to that
um i think
making your resources can take a super
like a very long time
whether that is creating your anki decks
or
you know creating flash cards setting up
a whole mind palace
that is the necessary stuff to do the 20
but there are ways that you can optimize
that if you think about you know you
have friends who are taking the same
courses as you
can you come together and create an anki
deck for the same course and optimize
that part of it so that when you're
doing the the 20 which is going to get
you the grade revising it um you've
already optimized your time yeah people
definitely obsess over how stuff looks
i've seen your notion
so
i appreciate it i appreciate that
there's a there's an aesthetic that some
people prefer to work in but you can
definitely overcook that
and you can spend so much time just
making stuff look nice
and it's low-key procrastination right i
am working yeah but you're not doing the
thing that actually matters you're not
doing something within the 20 that
creates the 80.
yeah oh this is i actually have a whole
section in my book about ditching the
aesthetics
because
i i had a lot of friends you know who
would labor over how their notes would
look and spend so much time directly
copying up
what they've done in class onto a new
piece of paper or onto a new flash card
and
have music blaring in the back and it
becomes a fun activity which is great if
you want studying to be
the fun part for you but thinking about
the the 20 which is going to get you the
grade if you're just purely looking to
optimize your time and definitely cut
out the aesthetics which the
highlighters yeah there's no science on
the highlighters being that so we should
be skeptical highly skeptical of
anything that's highlighted right fine
um
um what about coursework and homework
obviously not everyone is assessed
purely through exam what are some of the
tips that you've got for coursework and
homework
yes um i think routine is the best one
so i wrote a whole chapter about habit
formation and drawing on a lot of
incredible books like atomic habits i
don't know if you've read that book um
and sort of breaking down what is a
habit like if you look at the loop um
every habit is three things you've got a
routine which is you performing the
habit you've got something that cues you
doing the habit and then you've also got
a reward so something that you're
craving out of getting this habit done
so if you look at you know how you brush
your teeth every day what you're looking
for is the feeling of cleanliness or
that that minty freshness and then
you've built a routine maybe straight
away after getting out of bed you're
going and brushing your teeth
and then you you're getting that reward
you're craving it
and thinking about when you come home
from school for example what are you
doing first are you taking off your
school uniform are you
like getting a snack are you talking
with friends do you go on your phone
and if you can create a routine around
getting homework done at the same time
every day for a similar amount of time
it just takes out all the stress and the
friction
all of routines and habits are
eliminating friction because you're
making things no longer a choice you're
not choosing to come home and either do
your homework or go on your phone you've
decided that every day you're gonna do
your homework for like half an hour and
then you've got a whole afternoon to do
whatever you want
so
yeah if you can think about when you
come home what is it that you're doing
right now and how can how can you use
something that exists in your routine to
create a new homework habit so if the
first thing that you do when you come
home is get a glass of water maybe you
can say to yourself when i grab that
glass of water i'm going to walk
straight upstairs put it down on the
table and get out my planner and see
what homework i've got to do for the day
and then that's that's more likely to
stick to your routine because you're
attaching this new habit of getting your
homework done at that time to an
existing habit of getting your glass of
water every day
and then the more that you can repeat
this preferably over 30 days or a month
or so
um then it will it will just start to
not become a chore you know you come
home you get your glass of water you
come home you put it down you do your
homework and you don't think about it
and then all of a sudden you've got a
whole afternoon evening to do whatever
you want this is the equivalent for
people who are doing continuous
professional development whether it's at
work or whatever as well right you
finished work you drive home you get
home what am i going to do
one piece of advice that i would try and
give people is to probably reduce the
number of steps between doing the thing
that you already do and doing the thing
that you want to do so let's say that
you do get home oh well i might
go for a walk for a bit and then make
food and then
do a bit of stretching and then i'll go
and revise it's like no no just just get
to the thing that you don't want to do
as quickly as possible it's the reason
that morning routines work you do the
thing
that you're trying to do
before you can realize that you've
started doing it they're like oh god i
before i knew it i've actually done the
thing and now i've finished i think that
a lot of the time it is kind of like low
p low key procrastination
that people
don't really tell themselves it is when
i'm going to do this first and i'll do
that well yeah because i deserve a
stretch because if i use my back out if
my back's a little bit looser then i'm
going to be more upright when i'm
sitting and revise it's like no just get
it done
for
sure
good good well if it's got your seal of
approval that'll work so a lot of
students are probably
frozen by perfectionism and a fear of
failure and it sounds like at least at
school
that was something that you struggled
with how can people get past that
yeah oh it's such a tough one because
there are expectations from everyone to
do well you know like even if you're not
that invested in school you still know
that it's going to affect your life in
some way whether that is
next steps apprenticeships university
and there there's often a lot of weight
around the grades that you're getting
and i know that for myself
i develop quite an unhealthy
perfectionism around getting that next
better grade like even if i got 80
well why didn't i get 81 or 82 percent
um and i think the way that the school
system currently works where
you are just given these numerical
values off and off of what you just
wrote memorized um you can come to
associate your sense of self-worth in
these grades that you're getting and
it's not good it's not healthy
and some things that really help me are
taking a step back firstly and thinking
about the whole system in perspective
and your place in it because i think
when you're 14 15 16 all
your whole life is sort of going to
school and then doing stuff outside of
school and that's it so it's no wonder
that you are placing so much thought
into these exams
but when you see it in the grand scheme
of your life there are so many skills
and parts you as a person
which are far more valuable than this
grade you're going to get
and i think it reduces the perfectionism
when you see that you doing your best in
that moment with the resources that
you've got with the time that you've got
is enough it really is enough like you
are
gonna succeed whether you get the 80 or
the 81 whether you miss a grade and you
know you don't get what you're expected
to get whether you go to a different
university or plans change all you can
do is your best
and things are going to work out for you
you know you've got a whole personality
people skills other interests that
school can't grade you on and so
especially people who aren't that
academic
um
it's just worth seeing yourself outside
of this very narrow system that you're
currently in and trying to put less
pressure on it still motivate yourself
to do well within it and optimize your
techniques and develop habits like good
discipline but also not get too caught
up in what these grades could mean for
the rest of your life
that's a microcosm for the rest of your
existence
people obsess over a very sort of narrow
band
of
things that they're trying to do whether
this be becoming a chartered accountant
while they work at one of the big four
accountancy firms or whether it's
getting to a level of body fat
percentage whilst they're in the gym or
whatever it might be
we presume that
we magnify the impact that this
particular one pursuit is going to have
and obviously when you're younger if you
are 14 15 16 you don't have that breadth
of experience but i don't think that the
compulsion goes away as you grow up and
you get through your 20s
one of the things that i noticed that
happened i never had the perfectionist
trap
for academia ever a
very very sort of average student 2-1 at
uni and then a master's with a with a
pass like a high pass no merit sorry a
high merit but i never once felt that
lack
when it was oh i got 67 instead of 68
i'm like i think [ __ ] i got 67. i was
gonna get 57. yeah exactly survived
another year of university that was kind
of how i saw it however
where i did get that perfectionist trap
was in business so i attached my sense
of self-worth very quickly to the
success of the business what's the
revenue looking like how busy is it what
are the sort of reviews is it popular
and
that
compulsion it's just like this mechanism
which exists that that pulls people
along
and just because you've escaped it
for the students who
are
resonating more with me and saying well
i don't have this perfectionist concern
with
university or school or whatever my
developments it's like yeah wait until
you come up against the thing that you
actually do because there's probably
something out there that is going to
compel you to be completely obsessive
about it and these rules still apply
there is far more to you than
that one pursuit in your life you are
going to succeed and you're going to be
absolutely fine there's no mortal
catastrophe waiting for you on the other
side of a failed exam or a business that
doesn't do quite as well as you thought
it was going to for sure so just sort of
let it go yeah
and you know what you learn more from
failing it's just the truth you know
like when you do badly in a test or a
paper or you don't get the grade for the
university
you're gonna learn
you're gonna learn good things either
way and i think we have this assumption
that success is where you learn and that
that's like almost an achievement for
having learned all the lessons you need
to but in reality it's in doing worse
that i think you develop more as a
person so
just doing your best and
seeing the outcomes and either way at
all you're gonna get something out of it
floyd mayweather's the only person who's
got an unbroken record of wins i think
and pretty much everyone else has got
some yeah got some fails we're out here
struggling yeah i know yeah i'll try not
to be punched in the face
right 24 hours leading up to an exam
what should people do
oh okay so i think so much about going
into an exam is all about mindset
you've had all the time in the world to
do your last minute cramming to revise
everything and while i do think you
should go over a few a few things like a
few concepts that you potentially feel
weak on what you should focus on the
night before is
setting yourself up for being calm so
i'm a big advocate of mindfulness um
meditation
like it's not just a hippie thing where
you
you sit there and and pretend you're
breathing like it's it's an amazing
technique with a lot of science behind
it to prove that
even spending two minutes of just with
your eyes closed and doing intentional
breathing so breathing in for a count of
six and breathing out for a count of
eight and just repeating that
that can change your brain chemistry
already to be calmer
and i think this is a skill that you
should develop so that by the time the
night before an exam rolls around and
you are starting to feel that anxiety or
pressure about what's to come you sort
of can lean on that breathing technique
and find some calm within it so why are
you wanting to be calm
so your brain works a lot better when
you're calm you can access information
more easily you're more rational
you're you see time
more rationally too you're not rushing
to get things done or
um when you're you're hitting that exam
room and there's a question that you
don't understand
instead of
you know getting stressed and panicked
and seeing every part of your future
suddenly falling away from you
you can come back to that breathing
technique find a sense of calm and then
work through it as methodically as
possible if someone is
feeling that anxiety and they know that
they're a little bit behind in their
knowledge for the exam the next day what
would be the best strategy for getting
the most information in the quickest
yes um so i recommend having a cheat
sheet
it's a bad name you're not cheating but
just having a sheet of paper where as
you've been going over
going over all the topics there are
things that you feel weak on you just
shove them on the cheat sheet on the
cheat sheet and then the night before an
exam you can just go back through those
and i really do recommend blurting it's
a brilliant technique
you you pick those things and you just
write them you write whatever you can
remember about that topic and then you
go back you check your notes whatever
you don't remember
you add it in and then you do it again
you just blurt it out again to yourself
you write it down hopefully remembering
those new things that you've just looked
at in your notes and you just keep doing
that until you feel like you have more
of a grasp on that last minute concept
have you ever pulled an all-nighter
before an exam
not a full all-nighter no but like i've
definitely done the cramming and it's
it's not i think it's overrated
personally as a revision strategy
yeah
it's not enjoyable i can tell you that's
not enjoyable yeah
like you're trying so hard to lean on
your short-term memory but then you're
sacrificing
the thing that compounds your memory
which is sleep because when you're
sleeping everything that you're learning
is going in you know
it's if you're skipping the most crucial
part of the night then the next day
you're not going to be as rational
you're more prone to stress especially
if you've been leaning on coffee you
know you've got a higher heart rate um
so
i don't think it is the best strategy
but i understand why people do it you
feel compelled to stare at as much
information put it in your head as much
as possible i remember one exam there
was this drip somewhere in the house
that i was living in at uni
and it was dripping randomly about once
every seven seconds really loudly and it
kept me uh it kept me up until it was
like japanese water torture and uh i
ended up sleeping on the couch woke up
three hours later blee reid one of the
boys came down and said all right mate
if you pulled an all-nighter like not
quite kind of
kind of but it wasn't i wasn't revising
all right so um
we've
done some breath work we've made sure
that we feel nice and calm and cool and
controlled cheat sheet and some blurting
to i hate that word to get
but you remember it well yeah but
remembered it in the same way as
stepping in a pile of sort of something
unsavory is memorable because it's
terrible um so we've done that on the
night time we've tried to get as much
sleep as we can do
waking up the next morning what then
okay so something i really recommend is
positive visualization
so the idea is close your eyes kind of
similar similar to meditation
and you imagine yourself in the example
and for some people just the thought of
doing that will bring up feelings of
fear
because you know you're imagining a past
exam where you ran out of time or where
you didn't understand something and just
noticing whatever feeling comes up and
then instead doing the opposite and
visualizing it going really well you're
visualizing yourself being really
confident in that seat you're
visualizing going through being calm
being rational being methodical with all
these questions approaching something
that you don't understand working
through it and just imagining the best
version of yourself in that example and
i think the whole fake it till you make
it thing is amazing for mindset on the
day of an exam but more practically
something i go through in my book is
kind of a it's like a tick box um under
the acronym of morning
so for my memory it's m is materials so
you're going to go through you're going
to check that you have everything from
your pen to your calculator especially
if it's a maths exam there is no greater
stress than someone having forgotten
their calculator on a calculator maths
exam
um secondly in morning is oh organize
early
i think waking up even 20 minutes
earlier than you might usually do it
just reduces stress it allows for that
early bit of traffic in the morning or
something going wrong
um thirdly revise this is optional but i
think
leaning on your cheat sheet again going
over anything last minute that you feel
a little bit uncomfortable with you can
do this on the bus to school
fourth is
no stress conversations
i think this is a honestly one of the
biggest things that makes people get
into that exam
scared anxiety hype before an exam is
you know your mate going up to you and
being like
oh my god jade i heard that the
question's gonna be about
insert topic that you know that you have
no idea about and it's just really hard
and you're like oh my god what if this
comes up like i'm done my future's gone
um or people you know asking you to
explain concepts and you realizing that
you don't know it i think there is
something so stressful about that lead
up so if you can trying to step out of
these stressful conversations is a
really good way to set yourself up for
success um
and then in the morning acronym i is for
inhale exhale leaning on breathing
techniques as you're going into an exam
hall is great just to set yourself up
um and then the n and the g just to like
finish off morning n is for a nice
reward what are you going to be doing
after this exam it's not going to last
forever tonight you can go home you can
watch a series
and then g is for go for it and just
smash it
there's an equivalent to the no bad
conversations thing before crossfit
workouts so in crossfit there is a big
event called the open and they release
the workouts
shortly before you actually have to do
them and then everybody all over the
world does them together and what
happens on a friday night in gyms people
will arrive and everyone will warm up in
a room together so the 7 pm heat will be
warming up foam rolling and talking
about whatever whatever and everyone
that's in there is usually saying some
variant of this is really going to hurt
how many reps are you going to go for
like have you got a particular process
that you're going to go through here how
are you going to split it up
i'm going to try and go i'm broken i'm
gonna try and do this and um
yeah when you're trying to
keep heart rate low
and
focus on
having distractions that just make you
feel more and more sympathetic that make
you feel more and more
concerned and neurotic
it's not going to work
for sure
but it is hard to step out of them
yeah it is
and
the number of times that people have
stood outside of exam halls i remember
at uni
standing outside of exam halls and just
i don't know part of it it almost feels
like a pressure release valve but i
think another bit of it is that you
you're giving yourself
the opportunity to almost forewarn
people
about why
you see this again in in crossfit so
people will say
oh man i'm really not looking forward to
this workout because like last week last
week i was i was doing some overhead
work and my shoulders just sort of still
not quite there and today's got a lot of
overhead work in it and what you're
basically doing is forewarning other
people look if i don't perform in this
particular workout i've
put out into the world my excuse for why
i shouldn't be as culpable as perhaps i
i would have been and it's kind of the
same thing that our dude i don't think
and the number of people that
there's so many different archetypes the
guy that goes in and you know has done
tons and tons of revision but says yeah
i haven't really prepared that much the
really you know the really smart person
that you know is going to walk through
the exam the stupid person that doesn't
really matter and always seems to get
lucky you know there's all of these
different archetypes and what you're
doing is allowing your mindset to be
dragged away by each of their different
identities
and you know what it comes down to
it's fear of failure again
because no one wants to fail even if
you've spent 10 hours cramming the night
before
you will always have this feeling of
i've not done enough and something about
giving that excuse to other people as
you say is like a get out of free card
on results day and gives people that
that reason for you to not have done as
well but it's mainly for yourself
what
about in between exams
so giving yourself a little reward after
the exam might not work if you're just
going back to back to back
are there any strategies for maintaining
motivation throughout an extended exam
period
yeah i think firstly a nice reward
should always come it doesn't have to be
massive
like i had a friend who binge watched
friends throughout the exam season and
she would reward herself by like
watching two episodes after any exam and
then the rest of the evening was spent
revising for the next one and i think it
is nice to have something that marks a
separation from today and tomorrow
so no matter how it went today you can
sort of sit with it
you know okay it went really [ __ ] like
it's fine we'll just get on with it the
next day
um yeah so like let yourself to grieve
if you feel like it went really badly
let yourself celebrate if it went well
and then
refocus to the next one i recommend even
putting out the revision resources for
the next day's exams so there's no
friction like you can get home you can
have your little reward and then you
just sit down and you just get on with
the next one
i like it anything else any things that
you think we haven't covered for people
that are struggling with their exams and
their revision
[Music]
i know i've briefly touched on it but i
really think it's the idea of just doing
your best and what i say to some people
after they've done an exam that went
really poorly they're like oh but that
wasn't my best that wasn't my best
performance you know i've done better in
past papers and they're kind of missing
the point
it's not about
your best of all time it's not your
personal best it's your best in that
moment with those circumstances on that
one day where yes you're going to be
tested on the last two years of
knowledge but you did your best in that
moment and i think people really need to
remember that and cut themselves some
slack
if people remember that experience so go
back to the exam
that you've failed in and if you can
actually put yourself in there were you
thinking as you looked at the piece of
paper
i'm really not not bothered about trying
my best with this no you tried to
wrangle every single
megahertz of mental horsepower to try
and deploy it onto that paper you were
giving it everything that you had what
you're saying is that it just didn't
come out the way that i thought the
outcome wasn't the best
but the performance usually is it's very
rare that you actually go into anything
and don't give it full beams and if you
do then all right it's a learning
opportunity
for sure
yeah
i love it jade thank you very much for
coming on the only study guide you'll
ever need simple tips tips tricks and
techniques to help you waste your
studies and pass your exams will be
linked in the show notes below and if
people want to check out more of your
stuff where should they go
yes you can find me on youtube at
unjadedjade i'm also the same on tiktok
instagram and most other social
platforms
cool enjoy berlin
thank you
thanks so much for having me chris thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few months and
don't forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed
peace
you